sometimes it falls upon a generation to
be great
you can be that great generation global
citizen is a worldwide movement falling
on world leaders to adopt policies that
were chiva world free from extreme
poverty by 2030
the clean drinking water crisis is a
major crisis of our time we can get just
one wool girl in school every day it
changed the world we have to look at the
things we take for granted like waste it
really is up to us the government's and
corporates to be able to provide aid
this campaign is not just important it's
critical and crucial you have an immense
social following and so we'd love your
help you can count on me for that people
can hear us in culture we know when
citizens use hairballs
but these institutions can respond is
part of my duty to bring awareness and
activate people it really does connect
extreme poverty there is a
responsibility by those who have the
privilege to amplify the voices of those
who might not there's hope there's real
hope we will end extreme poverty we have
to
[Music]